I go to a Baldwin senior high school Rob
into a high school Horace Mann School
Rock Center for science and mathematics
a Collegiate School on the Upper West
Side go to NYC high school
we only accept the very best and the
very brightest so congratulations to
those of you who were admitted here
we're studying oxycodone and how people
get addicted to it my research is in the
lab of dr. Gunter blobel he actually won
the Nobel Prize in 1999 but my research
specifically was looking at messenger
ribonucleic acid and how that influences
its fate in the cell your DNA is
actually pretty important believe it or
not so your cells need to be able to
repair it so I studied the mechanism of
repair my research is looking at
oxycodone and how that would affect male
and female mice differently I work in
the laboratory of molecular metabolism
in which I study obesity and type 2
diabetes in the connections between the
two my research was about kombucha which
is a drink known for his probiotic
properties what I was trying to figure
out is what kind of yeast and bacteria
are present in commercial kombucha
versus homemade kombucha I was learning
techniques and really getting to work
with lab equipment and lab lab
interfaces and lab experiences that you
know is unparalleled
in in a high school setting one of my
very first lessons is that there's going
to be error in conducting research and
one of the most important qualities of
being a scientist is patience and
perseverance all part of the learning
process and that's taught me that be
afraid of mistakes to be be encouraged
be learned from them and then move on
through working with my mentor and the
other students in this program I kind of
found a community of people who like
science just as much as me and are
committed to kind of learning and
teaching science when I came into this
program I wasn't sure I want to be a
scientist I've always had an interest in
and I've always really liked the way
that scientists view the world but it's
really it's really cemented that
fascination for it like I know I'm going
to be really heavily considering it as a
career
because I just I had a great time
there's just a lot of opportunities for
everyone to do science and you shouldn't
just have this one image of Sciences is
just it's for everyone anyone can do it